many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
even though the vaccine is safe
effective and free this is not about
freedom
or personal choice it's about protecting
yourself and those around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
president biden's new plan to fight
coven 19 now requiring all employers
with a hundred or more workers to fully
vaccinate their workforces or show a
negative test at least once a week the
efforts also impacting hospitals home
health care facilities and all the
executive branch federal workers and
even federal contractors but our next
guest says these mandates are missing
the mark fox news medical contributor dr
nicole sapphire joins us now good
morning dr sapphire
good morning ainsley good morning the
executive branch they don't have a
choice they all have to get vaccinated
federal contractors have to get
vaccinated they they they don't even
have the option to test every week and i
heard claudia tinney a congresswoman
from new york this morning say she had
two constituents call her and say they
were pregnant their doctors told them
not to get the vaccine until after the
baby was born and they were fired what
do you say about this
well i can tell you ainsley throughout
the country right now we are starting to
see um shortages in staffing whether
it's nurses technologists and now i
suspect you're going to see other
staffing shortages coming from these new
mandates and these are all man-made
shortages
there were a few things ainsley last
yesterday that i heard president biden
say that i liked he discussed
increasing production of the monoclonal
antibodies that's great we need those
are proven effective to keep people out
of the hospital he didn't go far enough
saying that he was going to expand
access to outpatient centers and even
primary care doctors to be able to give
those monoclonal antibodies so that
doesn't help that much he also said he
was going to increase production of
those rapid antigen tests through the
defense production act that's great but
what he didn't say is he didn't say that
those rapid tests are going to be in
lieu of children having to be kept home
in quarantines because of close contacts
or even employees we need to move the
mark forward to actually help people we
need to keep our children in school with
these rapid tests we need to keep people
at work because we have so many people
unnecessarily quarantining so again he
didn't go far enough and if you think
his obvious disdain for the people who
have not gotten vaccinated helps people
like me convince the vaccine hesitant to
get vaccinated you're absolutely wrong
and so moving forward by saying that he
wants to protect the vaccinated from the
unvaccinated with these mandates he's
just further undermining the confidence
in the vaccines the message should be
these vaccines are doing a great job at
protecting people from severe illness
and death and he should encourage
everyone to talk to their doctors but
unfortunately he continued with his
group think
regarding vaccines which is completely
wrong they are far too black and white
they are not providing medical
exemptions for some people who may have
some sort of medical condition where
their physician doesn't believe they
should be vaccinated or maybe they've
already recovered from covid19 and have
natural immunity and likely don't need
two doses this group think is completely
wrong and the biden administration
continues to miss the mark by not
following the science there are reports
that some women say they've seen changes
in their monthly cycles have we studied
how this affects reproduction for folks
who have had the vaccine
well the nih is now putting forth about
1.5 million dollars to various
institutions across the study because
there have been reports about that but i
don't want people to get concerned about
that because you have to know when it
comes to menstrual cycles a lot of
things can alter that heavy exercising
stress medications and just just daily
life can alter your menstrual cycle
because of reports of it they are going
to look into it but it's possible the
inflammation from the vaccine may have
changed a cycle for a month or two this
doesn't translate to long-term fertility
issues there is a professor at the
university of california and he's suing
over the vaccine mandate because he says
he has natural immunity
is that something that they should
consider if you have natural immunity do
you have to get the vaccine if it's if
there's a mandate
i think it is high time the cdc other
elite institutions and biden
administration start acknowledging the
ample data that shows that there is
protection from natural immunity the
cdc's website only
discusses one small case control study
out of kentucky that showed that there
was a higher rate of reinfection
following
a infection than vaccination but that
goes against all of these other studies
throughout the united states and
throughout the world which are much
larger studies that show there is great
protection from natural immunity there's
also very good protection even better
from one dose of the vaccine following
infection they don't necessarily need
that second dose why they cannot get
past this black and white everyone needs
the two doses it really boggles the mind
the cdc acknowledges natural immunity
with so many other viral infections but
they're they're getting in their own way
right now when it comes to acknowledging
natural immunity we need to focus on the
people who are not vaccinated who have
not recovered from covet 19 those people
still remain the most vulnerable
dr sapphire thank
you you ainsley you're welcome